all that's left of these houses in the
city of ganja
the azerbaijanis who lived here know
they were lucky to escape
this rocket attack and they're
in no doubt who is responsible
[Music]
armenians did it but we're not afraid we
stand here
we will not leave
the government of azerbaijan is already
threatening retaliation
and not only for this
in recent days the armenian armed forces
have fired more than 10
000 shells at various cities and
settlements of azerbaijan
treacherous cowardly rocket and
artillery attacks
but armenia denies the attacks
neither artillery shells nor missiles
have been launched from the territory of
armenia
to the territory of azerbaijan yet
armenia accuses azerbaijan of continuing
to shell the disputed region of nagona
carabash
including its capital
although officially part of azerbaijan
the territory is run by ethnic armenians
and its leader there has admitted his
army destroyed a military airport in
ganja it's unclear how many have died
since clashes erupted
last weekend but this has been the
heaviest fighting between
armenian and azerbaijani forces
since a ceasefire was agreed in 1994
both sides claim the other is targeting
civilians
and with turkey now wading in to condemn
armenia
no one knows how this will end
you